if you're a Bradley Martin fan do you
think he has a better opportunity
against Mighty Mouse
because he's 130 pounds maybe 140
walking around or does he have better
opportunity to have success at Gates a
guy like Mike Perry who's slower than
Mighty Mouse he's not a high level black
belt he's not a high level Grappler he
doesn't have a wrestling background
I told Brian I said if if I'm Bradley
it's just grappling I'm taking my shot
with Mike Perry as far as grappling goes
might have asked me hard to get under
you're not gonna get a single leg now
you can be able to pick him up and do
that whatever the good luck Mike Perry
you have more realistic a bigger body
you know easier to get to his legs the
strength there with you know not as
skilled as a Mighty Mouse I think he has
a better opportunity to out grapple Mike
Perry I don't think y'all grapples in
him would be very clear but if you're on
team Bradley Martin you'd rather see him
go against Mike Perry than Mighty Mouse
now the intrigues is Mighty Mouse is
Tiny his name is Mighty Mouse But Mighty
Mouse is so skilled